en el último vídeo vimos la extracción
de la molécula de micro benceno y vimos
que el grupo litro
es un director meta debido a esta carga
formal de uno en el nitrógeno justo al
lado de tu anillo
también decimos que el grupo nitro es un
desactivador lo que significa que la
molécula de micro benceno reacciona más
despacio que el benceno por sí mismo en
una reacción de ni tracción veamos si
podemos descubrir por qué el grupo nitro
es un desactivador en términos de tanto
el efecto inductivo como el resonante y
empezaremos primero con la inducción la
cual sabemos se debe a la diferencia en
electro negatividad y podríamos pensar
en este nitrógeno de aquí comparado con
este carbono en el anillo el nitrógeno
siendo mucho más electro negativo y
entonces puede jalar electrones más
cerca de él y podemos mostrar el
movimiento de electrones hacia el
nitrógeno un hidrógeno cargado
positivamente es extremadamente aceptar
de electrones y podría incluso dar
densidad electrónica de tu propio anillo
eso hace al anillo más positivo lo que
desestabilizará
el complejo sigma que resulta en el
mecanismo para la sustitución electro
física aromática ya que es menos
probable que se forme el complejo sigma
eso desactivará al anillo hacia la
sustitución electro física aromática
también podrías pensar en el efecto
aceptar de electrones de este grupo
nitro haciendo al anillo menos núcleo
físico
y entonces ambos de esos factores
significan que el grupo nitro es un
desactivador hacia una sustitución
electro física aromática la inducción
dice que el grupo nitro es un
desactivador veamos ahora la resonancia
podríamos dibujar una estructura
resonante cierto donde tomamos estos
electrones y los movemos acá lo que
empujará estos electrones a nuestro
oxígeno continuamos dibujando eso
tenemos nuestro anillo
tenemos electrones pi en nuestro anillo
ahora el nitrógeno está doblemente
enlazado a nuestro anillo y tenemos un
oxígeno en la derecha el cual tiene una
carga formal de menos 1
el nitrógeno está enlazado a un oxígeno
en la izquierda el cual ahora tiene tres
pares libres de electrones y por lo
tanto tiene una carga formal de menos 1
déjame continuar y resaltar esos
electrones aquí
si estos electrones en azul se mueven al
oxígeno eso da a ese oxígeno una carga
formal de menos 1 este nitrógeno tiene
una carga formal de más 1 y continuamos
siguiendo estos electrones y también en
rojo estos electrones pil se movieron a
acá para formar este enlace pin quitando
un enlace de ese carbono por lo tanto
dándole a ese carbono una carga formal
de más 1 y podría continuar dibujando
más estructuras resonantes y tendrían
una carga positiva en el anillo pero
pararé aquí porque el punto al que
intentó llegar es que el grupo nitro
está sector de electrones y hace al
anillo más positivo lo cual por supuesto
desactiva el anillo hacia una
sustitución electro física aromática
ambos el efecto inductivo y el efecto
resonante dicen que el grupo nitro es un
desactivador y por lo tanto podemos
decir que es
desactivador fuerte por ambos por esos
efectos veamos otra molécula que es
considerada un desactivador fuerte esta
molécula de aquí abajo podemos ver que
hay un carbono enlazado a nuestro anillo
de benceno y ese carbono está enlazado a
tres átomos de flúor podría llamar a
este grupo three flúor o metido
podrías llamarlo grupo cf3 como desees
llamarlo en términos de diferencia en
electrónica tividad obviamente el flúor
es mucho más electro negativo que el
carbono por lo que podrías pensar en
estos átomos de flúor retirando mucha
densidad electrónica de ese carbono lo
que daría a ese carbono una carga
parcial positiva
y esa es una explicación de por qué el
grupo cf3 es un director meta nuevamente
mira el último vídeo para más detalles
acerca de por qué una carga positiva al
lado de tu anillo favorece un ataque
meta en términos del efecto inductivo en
el anillo
estos son átomos muy electro negativos y
entonces pueden retirar algo de densidad
electrónica de tu anillo por lo que
puedes mostrar los electrones de tu
anillo moviéndose en esa dirección hacia
tus átomos de flúor electro negativos y
eso retira densidad electrónica del
anillo haciéndolo más positivo lo que
por supuesto desactivará al anillo hacia
una sustitución electro física aromática
y este grupo tri flúor o metilo es tanto
un director meta como un desactivador y
este efecto inductivo es tan poderoso
este grupo cf3 resulta ser un
desactivador fuerte no podemos tener
ningún tipo de efecto resonante aquí
porque estos para el libres de
electrones en uno de los átomos de flúor
solo escogeré este de aquí
esos están demasiado lejos del anillo
para participar en la resonancia solo en
el efecto inductivo pero resulta ser uno
muy poderoso veamos un ejemplo más de un
director meta y éste es un desactivador
moderado
primero intentemos saber por qué este es
un director meta y entonces si vemos al
átomo que está enlazado directamente al
anillo que está doblemente enlazado a un
oxígeno y sabemos que el oxígeno es
mucho más electro negativo que este
carbono así que podríamos pensar en este
oxígeno como parcialmente negativo
jalando algo de densidad electrónica
hacia él retirando algo de densidad
electrónica
lejos de este carbono dándole a este
carbono una carga parcialmente positiva
y nuevamente tienes una carga
parcialmente positiva junto a un anillo
lo que hace a este grupo un director
meta
en términos de la desactivación
necesitamos pensar en estructuras
resonantes pensamos en mover estos
electrones en este enlace ti a tu
oxígeno así que continuemos dibujando
ese tenemos nuestro anillo de benceno y
tenemos ahora nuestro carbono con solo
un enlace sencillo a este oxígeno
este oxígeno tiene ahora una carga
formal de menos 1 a 5 y luego este
carbono está aún enlazado a este grupo r
quitamos un enlace de ese carbono por lo
que ahora este carbono tiene una carga
formal de 1 completa así ahora podemos
mostrar una estructura resonante para
esto tenemos que estos electrones bill
pueden moverse acá para formar un enlace
pi entre esos los carbonos
continuamos mostrando esta estructura
resonante tenemos nuestro anillo
estos electrones
ahora hay un doble enlace aquí y este
carbono aún está unido a este oxígeno
este oxígeno tiene una carga formal de
menos 1 y hay un grupo r enlazado a ese
carbono mostremos estos electrones pri
moviéndose aquí estos electrones se
movieron a aquí
quitando un enlace de este carbono por
lo que tenemos una carga formal de 1
justo aquí y por supuesto nuevamente
podrías continuar mostrando más
estructuras resonantes
pero sólo intento resaltar que la
presencia de este grupo incrementa la
carga positiva en el anillo y entonces
el anillo es más positivo lo que
significa que se está desactivando hacia
una sustitución electro física aromática
y entonces este grupo es tanto un
director meta como un desactivador ahora
pensemos en una manera general para
reconocer estos desactivadores moderados
aquí si regreso a este primer dibujo en
la izquierda tenemos un átomo enlazado a
un anillo de benceno y ese átomo tiene
un enlace a un átomo electro negativo en
este caso es oxígeno y entonces ese es
el patrón que buscas un enlace pi junto
a un átomo electro negativo te dará un
desactivador moderado